somebody who's blown up on the internet
recently is liver king says it's all
natural what what's your generality it's
100 natural man that guy will go out
there you know and he will eat a full
liver that's raw he looks and freakishly
big and built and just everything about
him he knows what vitamins and minerals
are he's making you look at him and he's
saying i eat bones this is where the
minerals are and you need to pay
attention it's not in that box of cereal
i have never met somebody that's east
like he does or close to
that has health problems in that is
basically you know somebody that suffers
from being overfed and nutritionally
starved everybody that you look that
basically has a consumption model based
on his extremes you're going to find
people that are much more clear in the
mind much more clear in the body much
more clear in their spirit it's just
something that you you do notice